Hello world, it's Saroj. And what
is the future of deep learning?
That's the topic for today,
inspired by something that
Geoffrey Hinton recently said.
This talk is going to be
divided into three parts.
I'm going to talk about
how backpropagation works,
what the most popular deep
learning algorithms are right now.
And finally seven research directions
that I have personally handpicked. Okay,
that's the talk in three parts.
So let's get started here.
So this whole video was inspired by
what Geoffrey Hinton recently said in an
article. So Geoffrey Hinton is
the godfather of neural networks.
He's the guy who invented
the backpropagation algorithm
back in [inaudible] 86
which is the work horse of all,
almost almost all deep learning. Okay?
So without back propagation,
all the great things we're seeing in deep
learning would not be possible today.
Self driving cars, image
classification, language translation,
almost all of it is
because of backpropagation.
So this what Hinton recently said is
causing shockwaves in the deep learning
community.
He said that he was deeply suspicious
of backpropagation his own algorithm and
said, my view is to throw
it all away and start again.
And I have to say that
I agree with Hinton.
I know it's crazy, right? Because
backpropagation has just given us so much.
But if we really want to get to
artificial general intelligence,
we've got to do something that's more
complicated or just something else
entirely because it's not just about
stacking layers and then back propagating
some Eric gradient recursively that's
not going to get us to consciousness.
That's not going to get us to systems
that are able to learn a huge variety of
tasks.
Everything from playing games to piloting
an aircraft to figuring out the most
complex equations in the universe.
It's gotta be about more than just
gradient based optimization. So,
uh, let's first start. Let's first talk
about how backpropagation works. Okay,
so the billion dollar question is
that it's probably multibillion dollar
actually. How does the brain
learn so well from sparse,
unlabeled data? That's how
we learn. We don't sit there,
we don't have labels for everything
we're learning. If you look at a baby,
it's incredible how much it learns
without some kind of supervision, right?
It can learn how to do
all these different tasks,
stack blocks in all these
little to learn how to speak.
And there are no labels per se in the
sense that we use them in deep learning.
It's all happening unsupervised. And
when up and sparse means few, right?
So it's not about very dense
descriptive data. It's sparse, right?
There's a lot of zeroes in it and
yet we can still learn from it.
So how does it do this? Well, let's first
understand how backpropagation works.
So in backpropagation,
so first of all,
a neural network is a
huge composite function.
It's a function consisting
of other functions.
And these functions are all in
the form health layers, right?
So you've got to input layer, a hidden
layer, maybe multiple hidden layers.
And then finally an output layer.
And you can look at it as this four
step process that I've got right here.
So the first step is to receive a new
observation acts and a target label. Why?
So this could be some image of a
cancer cell and then the label cancer,
right? And it could be
either cancer or not cancer.
And so you'll take that input and you
already have the label, right? That's,
that's how backpropagation works. As long
as you know that label, you are golden,
but you've got to know the label. So
you take that input, it's an image.
Think of it as a series of pixels.
So it's just a huge group of numbers.
So it's a vector,
right?
So you take that group of numbers
and you then you go to step two,
you feed it forward through the layers.
What do,
what do I mean by feeding it forward?
You, you continually take that input,
multiply it by some weight value,
add of bias value,
and then activate it by
applying a nonlinearity to it.
And you continually do that over and
over again until you have an output
prediction. And I'm going to
go over this more in a second.
We're going to look at the code,
but once you have that output prediction,
you compare it to your actual prediction.
Real label by doing a difference,
the subtraction, right? You, you,
you're subtracting the actual from
the, from the predicted, right?
And that that difference cause this,
these are all just numerical values.
That difference is your error. And then
you go to the last part, step four,
back propagating that error.
So once you have that error,
you're going to compute the partial
derivative of that error with respect to
each weight recursively for every layer.
So you'll compete the partial derivative
with respect to the layer before.
And then you take that
error gradient that you,
that you just calculate it and use it
to compute the partial derivative with
respect to the next layer.
And you'll keep doing that every time.
And then what happens is you're going to
have a set of gradient values that you
can then use to update all the weight's
in your network for as many as there are.
So the process is input, feed
forward, get the error back,
propagate uptick, the weights, repeat
feedforward, get the error back,
propagate,
repeat over and over and over and over
again a hundred thousand million times.
Right?
And that is the backpropagation algorithm.
We're going to go into it in more
detail, but that's at a high level. Okay.
So the paper that I'm talking about
where hints and released this,
I've got it linked to right here, but
it's a very old paper. It's, it was,
it was done in 86 and the reason it was
created an 86 and the reason that Hinton
is such a gene is because everybody was
telling him this is not going to work.
You've got to think of something else.
But Hinton held strong to this belief,
okay? And I think that is the
mark of a good researcher.
If you really believe in something to
not let anything else influence what you
believe in, right? Stick to your
belief. If you're wrong, you're wrong.
But at least you stuck to
what you believed in and you,
and you listen to other opinions as well.
But you really,
you really believe in something.
So the reason that it works now,
and it didn't work in the 80s is because
we have the computing power and the
data necessary to have
these huge, amazing, uh,
classifications and these
amazing generations, right?
For classification and
generative models for both.
So let's just look at this
canonical example of a very
basic neural network that
uses backpropagation scratch out. The
input number four is just three inputs,
right? So we have, it's a three layer
network and put hidden and output.
I'm going to go through this kind of
fast because we were going to get to what
really matters in a second here.
And if you've already,
if you already know how backpropagation
works, just skip forward probably,
I'm going to estimate
five minutes from now.
So we have this very simple basic neural
network and the goal is to take some
input data and then predict
the output label, right? So
we've got some input data,
which is a series of triplets, zero zero
one zero one one you know, et cetera.
And then we have a set of associated
labels, zero one one zero.
So four zero zero one the
associated output label,
why is zero and then et
Cetera, et Cetera, right?
So those are our inputs and our outputs.
We have this nonlinearity
which is a sigmoid function.
It's an activation function. And,
uh, I'll talk about that in a second,
but we'll take our input data.
We'll take our output data and we want
to learn the mapping function rights.
And then given some new output,
zero one one or one zero
one some arbitrary triplet,
we'll be able to correctly predict the
output label as it should be, right?
So the first step is for us to
initialize our weight values.
So our weight values are a set,
are both matrices, the are,
they are randomly initialized matrices.
And so what happens is when we
have our input, right? So again,
remember just scratch out the fourth one.
It's cause there's only three.
It's a triplet. We'll take that input
triplet, multiply it by the weights,
and those are the matrices. And so
that's why you see these arrows, right?
The reason we're using,
uh,
they say we need linear Algebra in deep
learning is because the linear Algebra
takes the standard Algebra operations
like multiplication and division and
addition. And it applies it to groups
of numbers that are called matrices.
So Linear Algebra defines operations
that we can apply to groups of numbers,
matrices, for example, the dot product,
which is used heavily in deep learning.
That's in fact that is the multiplication
we use in all types of deep neural
networks. It's a way of multiplying
groups of numbers together,
which is what we're doing,
right?
We're taking our input and multiplying
by a weight matrix and then we take that
result and we add some bias value
in a bias acts as our anchor.
It's a way for us to have some kind of
baseline where we don't go below that in
terms of a graph,
think of like y equals mx plus B.
It's kind of like the y intercept for
this function that we are trying to learn,
right?
And once we,
we've multiplied our input times our
weight value added a bias and then applied
some activation function to it,
which is our nonlinearity the sigmoid
that's going to give us an output and we
just take that output and do the same
process for the next layer and the next
layer and however many layers we have.
Okay.
So that's what we're going
to do using the dot product.
And then we're going to back propagate
the error once we compute it.
So back propagation,
you don't need to know all of calculus
to understand backpropagation.
You only need to know really three
concepts from calculus, the derivative,
the partial derivative, and the chain
rule, which I'll go through in a second.
So first I'll go through the derivative.
So the derivative is the slope of the
tangent line of a function at some point.
And the uneasy way to compute
the derivative for some
function like say y equals
x squared or any function, is to compute
the power rule, which I have right here.
So you'll take the exponent and you'll
subtract one from it and you'll take the
original exponent and move it to the
coefficient. So for y equals x squared,
you take the to move it to
the coefficient, subtract one.
So then it becomes two x to the first,
which is two x.
So the derivative of y equals x
squared is two x. So the reason,
and so the derivative tells
us the rate of change.
It tells us how fast some function is
changing and what what is happening for,
for gradient based optimization in
neural networks and all of deep learning.
Most of deep learning is we have some if,
if,
if we were to map out all of the
possible error values on the x axis.
So just imagine these are all errors and
then all of the possible weight values
on the y axis, it would come out
to be a parabola just like this.
And what we want to do is we want
to find that minimum error value.
We want to find those wait values such
that it's going to give us the minimum
air value. And what that means is we want
to find the minimum of that parabola.
And the way we're going to
find that minimum of the
parabola is by computing the
derivative,
which tells us the rate of
change of wherever we are
and then we're going to use
it to update our weights such that
we are iteratively, incrementally,
continuously moving closer and closer
and closer and closer to that minimum
point.
And once we have that minimum point,
that is our optimal point where the
error is smallest and the weights are at
their most optimal values such that
the errors in the me, the smallest,
every time we make a prediction,
right?
That's why it's called gradient
descent in general, right?
So when we take this very, very popular
optimization formula, gradient descent,
which I just described,
and we apply it to deep neural networks,
we call it back propagation,
right?
Because we are back propagating an error
gradient across every layer that we
have.
And so the reason we know we need to
know the derivative is because we're,
because we're going to what we're actually
computing is the partial derivative
derivative. Because a neural network
doesn't just have one variable.
It has several variables, right? For
however, however complex your function is.
So,
uh,
we want to compute the partial derivative
of the error with respect to each
weight, right? So when
I say with respect to,
I'm talking about that way
and none of the others.
So we'll you can think of a
partial derivative as saying, okay,
well what is a partial derivative
with respect to x for this equation?
What that means is we are only computing
the power rule for x and we are
ignoring everything else.
So y to the fourth is ignored and
when we compute the derivative of x,
it's going to be one, right?
So then we are left with five.
Why now if we're doing the partial
derivative with respect to you, why,
then we don't care about x.
We only care about why we do the power
rule for why to the forest and it's for y
cubed plus five x because y
the derivative of y is one.
So then x remains.
So that's what we're competing.
We're competing the partial derivative
and that's what's going to give us our
air gradient.
The gradient tells us how,
which direction to move on that
parabola to get to that optimal,
that minimum point gradient descent. And
the last part is the chain rule, right?
Because a neural network is a
giant composite function, right?
But what did I just describe? I describe
taking an input value multiplying it.
So input times weight at a bias activate,
right? We've talked about this before.
Input Times, wait at abayas activate.
That is the formula that is happening.
That is the function, right?
That is happening at every layer.
And these layers are nested.
So every time you add a layer,
you're adding a nested function inside
of this giant composite function that is
the,
that is the neural network.
So the chain rule tells us how
to derive a composite function.
What you would do for a composite
function is derive the outside,
keep the inside and multiply it
by the derivative of the inside.
So that is a rule and that rule applies
recursively for as many nested functions
as you have.
So that's the chain rule.
And so now that we understand that we
can do back propagation, that there's a,
there's your calculus primer
on doing backpropagation.
So the rest of this very canonical
example is saying for 60,000 iterations,
let's feed forward that input
data through each layer.
And so what we do for each layer
and say, okay, we've got k zero,
that's our input multiplied by
the first synapse matrix. Uh,
by multiply,
I'm talking about doc product.
Thank you num Pi apply the activation
function or nonlinearity to it.
So the activation function and the reason
we do that is because a neural network
is a universal function. Approximator
I am, I am telling you a lot right now.
So just uh, don't worry if you
don't understand everything,
there's a lot more to come and then
rewatch this video and I've got a million
other videos on this stuff as well. So
I'm very excited right now. Where was I?
Okay. So we were taking the input
times the weight. We're at input time.
And so in this case we don't have a
bias, right? Because this is very basic,
but usually we have a bias.
So we're doing input times wait,
activate, okay, bye. Times. I'm
talking about doc product. So we say,
okay, and then you repeat
that again for the last layer.
And then two is going to be our output
prediction and then we compute the error.
But finding the difference between our
actual output and our predicted output.
Then we perform backpropagation.
We take that airway to gradient and we
see in what direction is this target
value by computing the activation of that
output value and multiplying it by the
error. And that's going to give us the
greatest value that delta, the change,
right?
And that Delta is what we're going to
use to update our weights in a second.
But we've computed the delta the gradient
for this layer right though the the
the hidden layer. Let's get it. Let's
compute the gradient for the next layer.
So recursively.
So we'll use the K two delta ticket,
see how much the k one value
contributed to the k two error.
And once we've got that k one error,
we'll come,
we'll do the same exact props process
again to compute the k one gradient.
So the first layer is radiant.
And once we have both gradients,
then we can up update both of those
wait values using those grades.
And we just do that over and over again.
60,000 iterations that is backpropagation.
So I want it to go into a tangent,
no pun intended, to talk
about derivatives and, and,
and great aunts and how
backpropagation works.
But back propagation is the
workhorse of deep learning.
And this is a great chart.
The neural networks do that shows many
different types of neural networks.
There are so many types of neural
networks out there. It's not just one.
There's a lot,
right?
And backpropagation is the optimization
strategy of choice for almost all of
them, right? Almost all of them
use labeled data and then back.
And then backpropagation
has an optimization strategy
to learn some mapping
function, right? Everything is a function
in life. Everything is a function,
love as a function.
Emotions are a function that
the sound of the airplane above.
And then relating that to how
fast velocity and you know,
all these different variables,
it's all you can represent everything
as a function. Math is everywhere.
Math is all around us. Math is beautiful.
It's beautiful. Seriously. Oh my God,
it's awesome. Anyway, um,
everything has a function, right?
So we're trying to learn the
function and supervise. Learning.
Using backpropagation is
a way for us to do that.
So how do artificial in biological neural
networks compare? So this is a very,
uh, basic view of how they
compare the idea. It, it,
it's such a rough, it's such a rough, the,
the initial perceptron
initial neural network,
we're so roughly inspired by
biological neural networks.
It wasn't like they were
saying, well, let's,
let's implement a neurotransmitter
and let's, let's implement, you know,
dopamine and dendrites in
all of their details. I mean,
neurons are these very complex
cells. It's very basic. All the,
the only inspiration is
saying you have some neuron.
It's got a set of dendrites
that received some input.
It performs some kind of activation, some
kind of activation on that neuron. What,
what that means is it decides
whether or not to propagate that,
that signal onward or not using
some function. And if it decides to,
then it sends it out. That's it.
That's, that's the extent of,
of of the inspiration between artificial
and biological neural networks. Right?
Because we have some input,
we compute some activation function like
Relu or sigmoid or you know there's,
there's many of them out there and
then we output the value, right?
So the brain has 100
billion of these neurons,
numerous stand rights and
it uses parallel chaining.
So each neuron is connected
to 10,000 plus others.
Compare this to computers,
right?
Computers don't have neurons
in terms of hardware,
they are made of silicon and
they are serially changed,
which means these transistors on or off
switches are each connected to two or
three others and they form logic gates.
So W and there are great
at storage and recall,
even though they are not as
parallelize as our brain,
they are still better than at some things.
We got to admit that we are like,
it's better at calculating
numbers in, in memory, right?
We can't compute a million times a
million, but a computer can. However,
what our brain is really good at that
computers are not his creativity, right?
We are able to take some idea that is
completely unrelated to another idea and
apply it and then it results in
some amazing innovation or task.
And we are great at connecting
different concepts together.
We are great at being able to learn
many different things and apply our
knowledge to many different tasks and
that's what we should be trying to do with
Ai.
And so there are some really key
differences between our brain and uh,
artificial neural networks.
First of all,
the everything in the brain is recurrent.
That means there is always some kind of
feedback loop happening in any type of
sensory or motor system, right? Not
all neural networks are recurrent. Um,
there's a lot of lateral inhibition,
which means that neurons are inhibiting
other neurons in the same layer.
We haven't seen a lot of
that in deep learning.
There is no such thing as a fully
connected layer in the brain.
Connectivity is usually sparse,
although not random. Um,
we usually,
we have fully connected layers at
the end of our networks like say for
convolutional networks. Uh, but in
the brain there are none, right?
Everything is sparsely connected, but
it's, it's smartly sparsely connected.
Brains are born prewired to
learn without supervision.
So we talked about this a little bit,
right?
How babies can know things even
though they don't, they aren't.
There aren't given labels or any
kind of supervision. And lastly,
the brain is super low power at least
compared to deep neural networks, right?
The brain's power consumption
is about 20 watts.
Compare that to arguably one of the
most advanced ais today. Alphago,
it used about 1200 CPU and 176 GPU
is not to train but just to run.
Just imagine how much,
how many watts that takes.
That's like an order of up an order
of magnitude more power than our brain
ticks, which is, which is
annoyingly inefficient, right?
So we can definitely, definitely,
definitely improve on that.
There's this great book by this Harvard
Psychologist Steven Pinker, which I've,
I've read and I would highly recommend
it called how the mind works.
And this book is from a
neuroscience perspective,
not a machine learning perspective,
but we need more of that.
We need more of that because there are
certainly a lot of secrets here that we
haven't figured out, but we're trying. So
this is a great book to read and it's a,
there's a great quote from that book
that I'm going to read out to you,
which I particularly like.
The quote is the brain is not a blank
slate of neuronal layers waiting to be
pieced together and wire it up.
We are born with brains already structured
for unsupervised learning in a dozen
cognitive domains,
some of which already work pretty
well without any learning at all.
Right?
Evolution has primed us to be able to
do certain things even though we don't
have any real time learning happening,
it's just wired into us, right?
So there is something to be said about
structure versus learning everything.
Anyway. Okay, so we talked about
that. So where are we today? Right?
So that was the first part.
And here's the second part and
then we'll get to the third part.
Research directions. So where are
we today in UN supervised learning?
We know where we are with supervised
learning. That means when we have labels,
but what if we don't have labels?
What we can divide machine learning
into two types besides supervised and
unsupervised classification
and generation, right?
These are two tasks and one metal way
of looking at it as is as creativity and
discovery when everything else is
automated. For us, when all of the, uh,
s you know, all of the brainless
labor that we don't care about,
when all of that is automated,
what's going to be left for
us humans is our two tasks,
creativity and discovery, right? What
can we create? What can we discover?
And we're, and we, and we can frame
though those things as classification,
discovery and creativity generation.
So for classification,
what is something clustering,
right?
Clustering is perhaps the most popular
technique when it comes to classification.
And there are many ways to cluster data,
right? If you don't have the labels,
but you do have the data,
maybe you can learn clusters for all of
these labels such that there that you'll
be able to know what
groups each cluster are in.
So it's like learning without labels,
right?
There are several strategies
to learn clusters from data.
K-Means is perhaps the most popular
dimensionality reduction techniques like t
distributed to the castic neighbor
embedding or ta Tss or principal component
analysis.
There's anomaly anomaly detection,
but most of them still used some
sort of supervised learning.
And the ones that don't
use backpropagation are
not necessarily better.
They're actually very simple algorithms.
Like k means is just, you know,
these four steps right here.
It's very simple.
It's just basic arithmetic and um,
that's where we are right now.
There's also auto encoding,
right?
Auto encoders are really popular
for unsupervised learning.
The idea is that if you
are giving some input,
tried to reconstruct that input as
your outputs, you have an input,
you learned some dense representation
and you try to reconstruct it from there.
And this is great for dimentionality
reduction, uh, learning, some feature,
some features,
et Cetera for generation.
Perhaps the most popular right now is
the generative adversarial network.
So I met the Creator, Ian Goodfellow. We
had a good conversation in San Francisco.
We had, you know, he's a
really smart guy. And really,
I mean the idea was so basic,
right? It was such a basic,
very intuitive idea.
Yet it is the reason behind a
lot of hype and deep learning.
Right now the idea is to have two
networks. One tries to fool the other,
right? You have a discriminator
and you have a generator.
And so what happens is
you have some data set,
let's say some images and you
want to generate new images
that look very similar,
but they're new. So what you do is
you take one network and it's a,
it takes an input of one image. It
applies some distribution function to it,
right?
Enlightened space.
So what that means is like a
golf Sian or something like that.
So it takes them Gosling distribution,
multiply it by that image.
And so the image is basically a group
of numbers, right? The pixel values.
And when you apply some
distribution value to it,
you change those numbers ever so slightly.
So then if you look at it as
a picture, it's the, it's,
it's a slightly modified picture and that
picture is then fake and it only does
this sometimes.
Sometimes it shows the real one,
it shows a fake one and the
discriminator is a classifier it,
right? So you know what the real
images and then you know what,
but you don't know if the the
fake image is fake or not. Right.
The classifier doesn't know.
So it's got it's so it,
it tries to classify the fake image
and if it gets it right or wrong,
you could take its prediction,
compute an error value
between the real and the fake.
And then again back propagate
an error gradient value, right?
So you are still using
backpropagation across it.
So the whole thing is what's called end
to end differentiable because we can
differentiate every weight value
in the, in this, in the system.
So even though there
are no explicit labels,
we are still using backpropagation.
It's self supervised.
So it's like we are creating the labels.
Another great example are variational
auto encoders where we are embedding
stochasticity inside of the model itself.
That means inside of the layers
we have a random variable.
What what that means is the neural network
is not deterministic or stochastic.
You cannot predict what
the output is going to be.
That means that if you have some input,
you feed it through these layers.
One of them is a random variable.
So it's a distribution
that's applied to that input.
What happens is the output is going to
be some unpredictable new output that you
didn't predict before, which is what
you're trying to generate. Right.
And lastly,
and these are the bleeding edge of
unsupervised learning models by the way.
And lastly is the differential
neural computer. So I,
I am going to go out on a limb and I'm
going to say that the DNC is the most
advanced algorithm currently that uses,
uh,
backpropagation out there.
Maybe,
maybe Alphago is better, but we
haven't seen the source code for that.
So I wouldn't know. But in terms of openly
available a source code, the DNC is, is,
is, is amazing. It's also highly complex.
There are so many moving parts in
a differentiable neural computer.
And I have a video on this,
just search DNC Suraj but there
are so many moving parts here.
You've got read and write heads.
Um,
but basically you are separating
memory from the network itself,
right?
So you have memory and the idea analogy
fit that they made was between DNA and
the brain, right? So you have DNA,
this, this is encoded external memory.
So you have an external memory store,
and then you have your,
your internal controller, right?
And so the, the, the, the,
the controller is pulling from the
memory and there are read and write heads
between the controller and
the memory. Uh, between there,
there are links between different rows in
the memory. Basically, you have, let me,
let me show you this.
Let me show you this.
You have so many different
differentiable parameters.
All of the, you of, you have read
and write heads, you've LSTM cells.
Every single one of these matrices are,
and every single one of these
major streets are differentiable.
So this is a gigantic, very complex
system and everything is differentiable,
right? So there's that. And so now,
and what they did was for the DNC was
they generated a random graph and have
different subways and they use it to try
to predict where someone was going to
go based on some questions,
which is just incredible.
They also trained it on family
trees and a bunch of other things.
But basically the best unsupervised
learning methods still require
backpropagation.
So my point here is that backpropagation
really is the workhorse of deep
learning even in the unsupervised setting.
But another thing I want to
say is that a lot of, uh,
deep learning research is all about making
small incremental improvements off of
existing ideas. And a lot
of times academia kind of
pushes us in that direction.
It pushes you to make incremental changes.
Maybe like tweaking one hyper parameter
or adding some new layer type or maybe
new, some new cell type, like a
gru or whatever. But if you have,
but if you, if you, if you
think of a radically new idea,
you can really shake things up seriously.
And the idea,
it doesn't even have to be that
difficult. It really does. It does.
It doesn't even have to be that complex.
Like think of games.
I think of generative adversarial
networks. It's such a simple idea.
You have two networks. One tries
to fool the other, that's it.
It's just two neural networks.
One tries to hold the other.
And young lacount said this is the
hottest idea in the past 20 years in deep
learning. And look at this. I mean this
idea was invented just two years ago.
Look at the number of
gains that have been,
have been inspired by that first paper.
There are so many,
and this is in two years.
All of these different can go on.
You could make an entire four month
course on all the different types of guns
out there.
So my point is,
anyone can think of a really good idea
when it comes to deep learning it, the,
the playing field is level for everyone.
So let's get to the future
research directions. Okay,
so the first one,
so my thesis is this,
is that unsupervised learning and
reinforcement learning must be the primary
modes of learning because labels mean
little to a child growing up, right?
So we need to use more reinforcement
learning, more unsupervised learning,
and then we're going to get to somewhere
somewhere better than where we are
right now. So the first, uh,
we research direction is
Basie and deep learning,
which is not discarding backpropagation
is just making it smarter.
What do I mean by this?
Baze Basie and logic is all about having
some prior assumption about how the
world works versus frequent tests,
which just assumes that we
have no assumptions, right?
So when you take Basie and reasoning
and apply it to deep learning,
you can have amazing results.
And this has been proven in the
case of variational auto encoders,
but deep learning struggles to model this
uncertainty. So when I talk one on one,
I'm what I specifically mean when I say
Basie and deep learning is smarter wait,
initialization and perhaps even smarter
hyper parameter initialization, right?
And this kind of relates back to a child
and how evolution has primed us to know
certain things before we've
learned them in real time. Right?
There are certain
learnings we already have.
We are weights in our head
are not initialized randomly.
When we start learning,
we have some sort of smarter
wait initialization. So
Basie and logic is is a,
is a great direction,
is a great research direction.
Just combining those two fields,
Basie and logic and deep learning.
The second one is called spike
timing dependent plasticity.
And a great analogy for
this is saying you know,
you're trying to predict if
it's going to be rainy or not.
You can go out there and you can see if
it's going to rain literally with your
own eyes or you can look at your roommate
who tends to take an umbrella every
time he goes out and every single time
he walks out with an umbrella it happens
to be rain. So rather than
try to go out there yourself,
look at it's raining or not,
instead you just look at your roommate,
see if he picks up an umbrella. And if he
does, you know that it's going to rain.
So you take an umbrella.
So the analogy applies to spike timing
dependent plasticity because you can't
properly back propagate for weight updates
in a graph based network since since
it's an asynchronous system,
so we trust neurons that are
faster than us at the task.
So it's all about timing,
looking at neurons and how fast they're
firing and using those neurons as a
signal,
as a signal for how we learn.
So suppose we have two neurons a and B
and a synopsis onto be the Std p rural
state that if a fire's and be fires
after a short delay the synapse will be
potentiated.
Okay.
So the magnitude of the weight increase
is inversely proportional to the delay
between a and B firing.
So we're taking timing into consideration
which deep pointing currently does not
do the time of fire.
The third idea is our
self organizing maps.
So this is not a new idea at all,
but that's okay.
That's another thing
that I want to mention.
There is so much machine learning and
deep learning literature out there.
There is a lot and a lot of times
the best ideas are forgotten.
They are lost in the mix because there's
so much hype around certain ideas and
sometimes it's unnecessary hype around
certain ideas and some of the best ideas
could have been invented 2030 years ago.
I mean look at deep learning, right?
So it's just all about finding those
ideas and self organizing maps are one of
those ideas where you know this is an
older idea but it has a lot of potential
and not many people know how these works,
how these work.
But this is a type of neural network
that is used for unsupervised learning.
So the idea is that we have,
we,
we randomize the node wait
vectors in a map of them.
So we have some weight vectors and then
we pick some input vector that's our,
that's our input data and we traverse
each note in the map computing the
distance between our input node and all
the other notes and then we find the
node that is closest,
the most similar to our input node that
is the best matching unit, the BMU.
Then we update the wave vectors of the
notes in the neighborhood of the BMU by
pulling them closer to the input vector.
And what happens is this creates a self
organizing map and you can visualize it
as different colors,
but it's a basically clusters of
different data points cause basically
clustering. And I think this is
a great idea. It doesn't use it.
It doesn't use backpropagation. Uh,
and we should look more into that.
The fourth idea, the fourth, the fourth
direction or synthetic gradients. So,
uh,
Andrew Trask has a great,
great blog post on this that I
highly recommend you check out.
It's really in depth. But this
idea came out of deep mind. Uh,
this idea came out of deep
mine and it's basically,
it's a much faster version
of back backpropagation in
which you are not waiting
as long to update your weights.
So individual layers make a best guess
for what they think the data will say.
Then they update their weights according
to that guest and they call this best
guessed the synthetic gradient because
it's a prediction of what the grading
will be,
not what it actually is.
And that data is only used to help
update each layers guesser or synthetic
gradient generator. And what
this does is it allows, uh,
individual layers to learn in isolation,
which increases the speed of training.
Individual layers can learn without
having to do a full forward and backward
pass. Uh, so that's synthetic
gradients. And I think, and,
and it's weird because even in
the machine learning sub Reddit,
people were talking about
synthetic gradients. Uh,
but some of the questions were, hey,
we need more of this. Why, why hasn't,
why hasn't this been talked about
more? And people don't know, right?
So this is a great idea.
I came out of deep mind and definitely
learn more about synthetic gradients.
The fifth research direction
is our evolutionary strategies.
So open AI had a great blog posts on this
evolutionary strategies as a scalable
alternative to reinforcement learning.
But evolutionary strategies have not
given us a lot of success so far,
but that's okay. Just intuitively
they make a lot of sense, right?
Trying to resemble evolution.
You have fitness,
you have a fitness function
that determines how fit
some individual is and these
individuals mates, right? So
there's crossover and you know,
it's basically survival of the fittest.
You have,
you have mutation selection and
crossover via a fitness function.
And you can do with a lot of games,
right?
So you can have several neural networks
and you can use evolutionary strategies
to have the best one win or,
or survive longer than the rest.
So I think there's a,
there's a lot of potential for that.
And it's very similar to
reinforcement learning. So if I,
if I were to pick the
lowest hanging fruit, right?
The lowest hanging fruit
in terms of revolutionary
ideas to come to the table of
really radical changes,
it would be in reinforcement learning,
deep reinforcement learning.
Reinforcement learning is all about
learning from trial and error, right?
You have some, you are some agent in
some, in some environments, right?
It's called the agent environment loop.
You perform an action in that
environment, you get a reward, yes or no,
and then based on that reward, you
update your state, your learnings,
and you continue that process.
So AlphaGo used reinforcement learning,
deep reinforcement learning to
get really good at its game.
And there are so many low hanging
fruits and deep reinforcement learning.
How do we learn the best
policy? Uh, uh, just there,
there are so many unanswered questions.
So reinforcement learning in
general is a great place to, uh,
do to just focus on in terms of research.
And the last one is the most capital
intensive and perhaps the hardest,
but I just had to mention it right?
We talked about how transistors
are on off switches and uh,
they are chained together serially to
four to perform to form logic gates,
whereas neural networks are,
are parallel in their construction so
they're connected to 10,000 other ones.
So perhaps instead of trying to replicate
the rules of intelligence in Silico or
at least, uh, on the current
types of chips we have,
let's just change the hardware
completely right at the hardware level.
And IBM's neuromorphic chips are good
example of going in this direction.
Google's TPU tensor processing unit.
But basically the idea is to wire up
transistors in parallel. Like the brain.
Really, I think, I think anyone can
can do this. You just, you know, you,
if you have some idea,
I mean, think about it,
the brain is only running on 20 watts,
so it can't be that expensive, right?
In terms of hardware wetware right?
So,
so if you have some idea you can crowd
funded for whatever hardware you want to
build and then, you know, use we
funder or Kickstarter and yes,
I think you can even have a startup for
hardware, for, for machine learning,
for deep learning.
So what is my conclusion?
Those are my seven research directions
that I wanted to talk about today as a
way, as a, as a response to Hinton
talking about backpropagation.
So what is my conclusion?
What do I think? I think.
And so I agree with Andre Carpathia
who is one of the best deep learning
researchers out there. He's a
director of Ai, a Tesla now.
And the conclusion is this,
let's create multiagent simulated
environments that heavily rely on
reinforcement learning and
evolutionary strategies. A carpet.
The Ed is great talk at y Combinator,
which I didn't attend,
but the slides are online.
But check this out.
He had this one slide
that said intelligence.
The cognitive toolkit includes but is
not limited to all of these different
aspects of intelligence,
attention, working memory,
long term memory, knowledge,
representation, emotions, consciousness.
There are so many different,
uh,
topics that encompass learning.
It's this orchestra of different,
of different concepts and they all
work together to define intelligence.
Our intelligence
to the conclusion is we need to create
environments that incentivize the
emergence of this cognitive toolkit.
So doing it the wrong way
is to use this environment.
What does this incentivized incentivizes
a lookup table of correct moves, right?
For pump.
But what is doing it right?
This two agents in this world, there's
some food, there's some survival.
They are learning to adapt to each other.
It's much more like real life itself,
right? And that incentivizes a
cognitive toolkit, cooperation,
attention, memory, emotions,
even right with more complexity.
So it comes down to the exploration
versus exploitation dilemma from
reinforcement learning.
How much do we want to exploit existing
algorithms backpropagation by making
incremental improvements versus how much
do we want to explore an entirely new
ideas.
And we need people doing both.
We need people improving the deep learning
algorithms because there's still a
lot to be improved upon. But we also
need people working on exploration,
like entirely new ideas.
In fact,
I think we need more people focusing on
that then we have currently. So if I,
if I were to, you know, take some away,
I would say let's take 20% and put them
20% from the exploitation and put them
in the exploration
category. But, um, yeah,
it's just something to think about.
I hope this video helped you think more
about all of these concepts and where
we're headed and where we should go.
I hope it gave you some ideas for
what you might be more interested in.
And I'm going to keep making
videos like this, so yeah,
please subscribe for more programming
videos. And for now, I've got to evolve,
so thanks for watching.